Cái mong ai tháng 2, chữ tiên là tổ chức lệ khánh thành chẳng trạng nhạc tính tổng hợp lớn nhất từ trên thế này.
Tại thành phố Xin Lú Chiu, khu vực về tây bác tự chữ thế thảy nặng này, giữa lụn năm 2020.
Nhà lãnh đạo chữ tiên, kinh trưng, tham dự và chữ tiếp các băng khánh thành,
gọi đây là một thành tự quan trọng trước thêm đại hội đảng lao động chữ tiên lần thích chính.
Theo chuyên thông chữ tiên, giữa nước hợp cóm từ tháng 2 năm 2020,
bác hồn hàng chăm nhà tính hiện đại, bởi nhiều chủ loại, chung tâm nghiên cứu sau qua,
khu nhờ kêu mởi cùng cơ sở phán hóa xảy chi, và kệnh quan đồng bộ.
Hấp dẫn, bởi vì lệ chủ tính chữ tiên trưng đánh xa cao về áp dụng hệ thống xả sốt tích hợp thủ mạnh,
tại trang trạng, cho phép tinh nối qua lý và xả sân nguyện hiệu quả hơn.
Sau bởi lấy khánh thành, nhà lãnh đạo chữ tiên là tham quan toàn bộ tổ hợp.
Dới chí trực tiên trở biết trang trạng nhà tính xinu chư, được ký vọng góc sân tăng cường 1 ngôn ngôn ngôn sàn,
và túc đầy phát triển tinh tệ địa phương trong thời gian tới.